[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
paradoxe économique d'un côté un chômage
bien présents autour de 7% en union
européenne lui % en france et de l'autre
une pénurie de main d'oeuvre et des
entreprises en manque de bras selon une
enquête de la banque de france presse
qu'une entreprise sur deux serait
confronté au problème en france et le
phénomène est mondial
au royaume uni début août on parlait de
1,1 million d'emplois vacants en chine
même constat les usines ont du mal à
embaucher tout ça s'explique pour
différentes raisons en fonction des pays
il ya d'abord le qu'ovide évidemment
mais aussi une reprise économique trop
rapide avec des usines incapable de
suivre une demande trop forte au pays de
l'union jack le brésil a fait fuir bon
nombre d'européens qui pouvaient
prétendre à certains postes 1,3 mio
aurait quitté le pays depuis le début de
la pandémie 700000 rien qu'à londres 8 %
de la population de la capitale anglaise
en chine le vieillissement de la
population joue un rôle évident et ça ne
devrait pas s'arranger puisque la
population active devrait encore se
réduire de 35 millions de travailleurs
dans les cinq prochaines années tout ça
ralentit fortement la relance économique
après la crise mais pourrait malgré tout
vous faire la paire de certains les
salariés et les personnes en recherche
d'emploi et oui la rareté de personnel
qualifié pousse les employeurs à offrir
de meilleures conditions de travail des
primes des augmentations de salaires en
chine par exemple pour la production du
futur iphone l'entreprise foxconn doit
se résoudre à verser les primes de 1200
euros par ouvrier au royaume-uni
certaines entreprises proposent des
primes de bienvenues allant jusqu'à dix
mille vivre reste à savoir si ces
conditions d'embauché rêver s'inscriront
sur la durée et si elle ne découvrons
pas par la force des choses sur une
augmentation des prix pour les
consommateurs
[Musique]